10 ans ça se fête
encore plus quand ça se passe encore une
fois à domicile en martinique
puisque la mercury semble avoir
définitivement quitté l'île de sainte
lucie pour s'installer aux anses d'arlet
au départ il s'agissait de la fête des
propriétaires de bateaux ayant des
moteurs mercury
aujourd'hui les participants arrivent
aussi bien de la terre que de la mer en
moyenne on reçoit à 3,253 son bateau il
ya déjà une grande partie qui s'est
installée et plus haut niveau des
participants
l'événement se veut grandiose
déjà hier soir un grand concert a réuni
sur scène les stars jamaïcaine romain
virgo et christopher martin
ce soir ce sera elephant man et pour
faire monter l'ambiance depuis le matin
de nombreuses animations et surtout les
dj qui se succèdent sur scène avec une
sonorisation exceptionnel
brault dispositif sur place un
dispositif qui vous permet de tirer sur
plus de 250 et ils entendent
effectivement à midi l'atmosphère était
déjà brûlante chez les festivaliers de
tous âges
on vient de décompresser on a lâché pour
commencer de bonnes vacances pour
poursuivre et on repartira vers pour les
études certains des festivaliers sont
malgré tout conscient que cette mercury
blick est parfois mal lu la faute au
bruit et aux danses lascives s'apprêtent
une nuisance pour les voisins mes vidéos
que c'est une des poches
jusqu'à maintenant c'est quand je vois
les photos que je me rends compte de
certaines choses plus au concours a moi
je vois pas ce genre se donnerait les
gens ouvrent leur est pile un petit peu
et sachez aussi un moment de détente
au final les organisateurs affichent une
tolérance zéro sur les drogues ils
promettent de respecter l'environnement
et la sécurité déployée est
impressionnante
espérons que tous ces engagements soient
respectés pour que la fête soit belle
jusqu'au bout